does anybody else out there get the
feeling that this administration thinks
we're idiots
listen Obama this isn't PBS so stop
talking to us like we're four years old
hi boys and girls
for example everyone knows that Obama
vowed to the Saudi King it was nothing
personal it's just that Obama has a
compulsion to be loved that rivals that
of a desperate chubby middle school girl
and Obama's people actually tried to
tell us that he was just bending over so
he could get a firm double hand and
shake - do you go boys and girls Obama
was really only bending down so he could
grab the Kings hand with both his heads
and the king said Obama matter that's a
firm hand Obama said the only problem is
the tape shows Obama's left hand glued
to his side and just as surely Obama's
press folks have tried to laud praise on
him as though he had anything to do with
the pirate hostage rescue pirates we all
know that the real people to think are
the members of the United States
military the same people Obama's been
undercutting at nearly every turn when
things go wrong however the Obama
rhetoric becomes painfully predictable
yeah the economy is pretty much getting
creamed but that's because it was on
George Bush's birth don't worry about
that let's just dance
[Music]
do you think this administration is
pandering to the lowest common
denominator and are the American people
really as dumb as they take us for I
mean it's pretty typical of the left to
spin things to sound more in their favor
it's not terrorism it's now man-made
disaster and now it's women's health
it's no longer abortion
I just I can't